you've entered the forge of Fire arena
to battle it out for a check for ten
thousand dollars the title of Fortune
fire champion and today also for this
WWE title
voice miss today's competition is all
about the WWE
the challenges and the tests are all
inspired by the most memorable moments
in WWE history
[Applause]
and up first the cage match
this is going to be an all-out battle
this is our version of the 1998 Hell in
a Cell match trapped inside this cage
are stacks of 1095 and 15 and 20 which
you will need to break free once you get
them out we want you to make Damascus
billets and because the WWE is over 40
years old we want those bills to be at
least 40 layers
with those billets we want you to build
signature blades in your signature
styles that measure between 13 and 15
inches all right boys miss you guys
ready to kick ass and leave it all on
the floor absolutely yeah yeah all right
you've got three hours on the clock and
good luck your time starts now
they said smash into it Micah okay
Josh is a beast man he just got straight
through that thing
when I saw cage matches when I was a kid
I just thought that was the craziest
thing ever and now here I am cutting
into this cage getting after it
all right Phillips in
there we go man Hunter's out
my game plan is to make sure my steel
stays very clean I'm gonna hit it all on
the grinder first before I try to set
those welds now that my steel is clean
it's straight into the fire
I could stack these up and get 10 layers
or I can cut them all in half and start
with 20. I'm going to go for a high
layer count the higher you go the more
tendency you'll have to shift and maybe
sheer welds okay and of course
we've only just started I already feel
like I'm behind everyone else
they're clean I'm doing it I'm not
cleaning these this is my opportunity to
jump ahead I'm just gonna weld this
thing together stick it in the Forge and
here I go Hunter went straight for the
welder you think that's a good idea it's
a wrist come on baby if I don't nail the
sports weld on the first shot it could
send me home so I stretch my 10 layer
Billet out about eight inches and that's
when I'm ready to cut and stack my
Billet so I can make those 40 layers I
take those four chunks and start
cleaning up those surfaces for a really
good forgewell
my staff took a good Weld and I'm just
super excited
all right big blue you and I are gonna
be friends now
I've got this Billet drawn out I'm gonna
try and impress the judges they wanted
40 layers I'm gonna throw 100 at them
once I get five pieces I'm gonna stack
them up that'll get me my Hundred layers
I feel good that my fillet's solid I'm
gonna start forming my tip good I'm
pretty confident in my blade right now
[Music]
want to do something extra I want to
throw a little raindrop pattern in there
I give them props for trying to get a
pattern when we didn't ask him to I
don't know if this is going to work but
if it does it'll look really good down
the road now that I have a rough shape I
have to go in for the quench because I'm
looking at the clock and it's running
out
there you go
there we go looking good I'm Overjoyed
that it's not warped because there is no
time to fix it anyways
that is nice time to quench
that's a hot blade
be so happy with it we'll see you when
you guys smash a chair into it I clean
it up throw it in the etch
I pull it out and it's got a beautiful
100 layer Damascus pattern that's
fantastic
smoke all I see is smoke I notice when I
pick my blade up that there is a warp oh
this could be enough to kick me home I'm
gonna see if I can work out some of this
warp before I just show it to the judges
I can make it work five four three two
one this round is over good work Welcome
to our WWE inspired strength test the
steel chair smash
this is gonna be a lot of fun now what
I'm gonna do is clamp each of your
blades in this mechanism take the steel
chairs and smash them into your blades
straight down over and over and over
again now what the knives do to the
chair
come on we're looking to see what the
chairs do the knives you know as well as
I do all right Phil you ready to go
let's do it
thank you
foreign
I could still see that crack on both
sides going across the Cutting Edge but
it didn't come apart so great job on
that you got a little bit of dulling
from the steel on the chair but you
still have Edge there good job thank you
all right Josh you ready to go are you
ready I love it when people try to
Heckle me I'm worried
oh
[Music]
well done sir thank you all right Josh
you survived good job The Edge on your
blade it's not super sharp but there's
still an edge there
not crazy about the handle though
it feels like my fingers are getting
squeezed in between these two high
points here I'm beefing up the handle
would have been a nice touch but didn't
affect this test at all so good job
thank you
you ready Hunter yeah let's go
foreign
your Edge you do have some chipping here
probably from too much heat in the
quench but your knife's in one piece
and the chairs toast so good job thank
you late Smiths welcome to the sharpness
test the turnbuckle attack now to find
out how sharp your weapons are I'm gonna
take your weapons and I'm going to be
cutting gutting and smashing this
turnbuckle flip your purse you ready for
this I'm ready let's do it all right
let's do it
thank you
all right so let's talk about your blade
here the areas that you have on your
blade that are on the top here are sharp
now it's a heavier blade but you know
what it's nicely balanced and overall
sir
it will cut
all right Josh it's your attorney you
ready sir I'm ready sir all right let's
do this
all right Josh let's talk about your
weapon here there are areas here that
took some damage during the strength
tests that are not sharp but the errors
that are sharp cut nicely on the
turnbuckle
now you're handled construction is just
so narrow that there are times when it
wants to spin around my hand because
there's space inside but overall sir
your weapon you look up thank you though
all right Hunter are you ready yes sir
let's do this
all right Hunter your blade cut deeply
on the turnbuckle and that is because
your blade has the thinnest grind among
all the other blades now your handle
construction it is wide enough that I
can be comfortable with the blade and
slashing and controlling your weapon
overall sir your weapon
you're welcome thank you gentlemen the
three of you guys battled it out in a
cage match but as you know only two of
you guys are moving forward in round
three the competition and the blade
Smith is going to be leaving the forges
Josh unfortunately your blade just
didn't make the cut and Dave's going to
tell you why Josh I got to tell you 100
layer count unprompted never happened
before and you should be very very proud
of that but that obtuse grind on your
blade lost a lot of its Edge in the
strength test and that spindly handle
it's just not big enough for that knife
and that's why we're letting you go
thank you well Josh man you fought hard
but unfortunately your time here has
ended and I'm gonna ask you to please
step off the forge floor bud
I'm very disappointed in the outcome
good work Josh I designed the blade to
survive the strength test I should have
put a little bit more into the sharpness
test but there's nothing I can do about
it now this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity I'm so glad I came and did
it